this week's videos are sponsored by manscape more
on them after the reaction people what is going
on there citizens of the reject Nation Greg and
John here today to watch the furiosa a mad mask
Saga trailer number one John how are you witness
my excitement g i uh haven't seen the movie in
a long time I'm assuming that's a reference I
saw it once under some extreme stuff sure yeah
I I could use a rewatch this to say ladies and
gentlemen right now uh John and I with the help
of a couple of other people my brother Brandon
mgar building a second space for us to film at
right now other people are filming at the main
space so we are just using this because we need to
at this moment leave a like on this video that'd
be very much appreciated guys let's see what the
hype is all about because we have been waiting
for another Mad Max film for a very very long
time whatever you have to do Chrome to it's
cool it's getting however long it
takes it's getting more and more
orange promise me you'll find your way
home the true origin story give me this
promise oh hell yeah with hair the origins
of how she became bald yes there's got to be
like a weep shave Montage a young furiosa is
taken from her family she will devote
the rest of her life to finding her way
home this is hery and if you want to know
how she found her way home watch the last
movie yeah the start of how she tried to
get home and spent a very long time doing
[Music] so was that Chris Hemsworth that
lady and oh my [Music] God didn't
recognize that there's so many app
Prosthetics [Music]
everyone oh it's beginning mhm and it's going to
get to use accent survive while the
bullets are flying in there wow whoa
oh love story too oh her arm with the sleeve
exposing it there we go ramp that engine up
woo God [Music] B the darkest of
angels oh nipple [Music] chills
damn it's like Army of Darkness the question is
[__] do you have it in you to make
it epic it's like Thor with a different
voice that's a pretty freaking awesome trailer
man yeah remember and witness me wow what a true
expansion on the Saga right here damn that was
great I just ran a mile seriously it's crazy
seeing Chris Hemsworth back with all that hair
and then fake teeth and like a fake nose and
then furiosa too with the shape John I'm trying
to transition to our sponsor Jesus Christ L The
Improv Mary balls reject Nation you know what
the funny thing is I already owned this product
before agreeing to do this partnership I could
have used my influencer ring to get it for free
or at a discount but hey now you can get it at a
discount cuz this week we are of course sponsored
by manscaped as a married man who's always on
the move I value looking sharp all keeping things
efficient and that's where manscapes performance
package 5.0 Ultra comes in featuring the lawn
mower 5.0 and it is a game changer the package
is honestly a perfect gift for yourself or for
another man that you might know I'll give this
to John if anyone ask I pay for it out of my own
pocket but no seriously this is easily the best
because it comes with not one but two NextGen
blade heads see the difference it's good thing I
have two now for demonstration purposes so you got
the standard trimmer for a perfect neat trim but
this one the new foil blade for that super smooth
finish and oh yeah it's all about safe grouping
with their Advanced Skin safe technology plus
they're waterproof so no more crumbs on the carpet
the package also encloses a weed whacker 2.0 for
ear and nose and I definitely use this because
look at me I'm a hairy guy and the musthave liquid
formations the crop Soother aftershave lotion and
the crop preserver ball deodorant say goodbye to
postet of irritation and hello freshness and the
ultimate cherry on top two free gifts manscapes
premium boxers 2.0 and the [__] 2.0 toiletry bag
again I already have one the boxers I'm wearing up
here right now and the bag is perfect for all your
grooming Essentials as you can see so you ready to
elevate your grooming game head to manscape.com
and use code rejects for a cool 20% off plus free
shipping remember it's rejects for 20% off
at manscape.com let's get those jingle balls
holiday ready with manscaped this is like a true
return to the Mad Max form of what it has become
since Fury Road with its insane eccentric kinetic
visuals on full blast here here uh the trailer
surprisingly breathed better in the beginning
Parts than I expected it to it feels like that
unlike the last movie which which I recall being
more of just this non-stop essentially very long
chase that there'll be those elements of course
you got to have apocalyptic Road chases in a Mad
Max film that it'll probably be a little bit
more character driven narrative as you would
probably hope for and expect considering this
is the origin tale of furiosa um it's it's it's
interesting because I I was most curious to see
like Anya Taylor Jord because Charlie ston was
uh you know the scene stealer in the last movie
and so it makes sense why she would get uh her
character at least would get the spin-off a lot
of people were disappointed by the fact that they
didn't bring back Charlie ston and they got Ona
Taylor joy in here I feel like the talk of the
trailer is probably going to be Chris Hemsworth
though you know um but he's often doing that at
female lils that Chris Emsworth boy knows how to
take the attention man I mean he just knows how to
have fun um but so I do want to talk about him but
for Anya Taylor Joy U my first impression at least
of her is I mean she does seem to demonstrate
that prowess you do seem like you're going to
get a good inclination of that growth and in terms
of An Origin tale we didn't really get a dive too
deep from my recollection into uh everything
the relationship she lost the relationship
she left behind and it seems like that's what
we'll see is really experience the things that
are Stripped Away away from her and that sense
of loss to understand why she's fighting to go
back home so badly uh this long build that we get
to in Fury Road uh but Anya Taylor Joy I think is
a phenomenal actress and it's cool to see her take
on a role that's going to require this much amount
of um strength in to put better word yeah what
do you think man durability no I'm super excited
and and yeah I mean I really like Ona Taylor
Joy I do feel like yeah she gets cast in like
tons of stuff now so she's kind of bordering
on that on that edge of maybe being like you
know female Pedro Pas c a little bit or female
uh Chris Pratt's voice acting career the moment
um but no like I I really like her in general and
this is an exciting prospect to me because this
is the kind of movie that an actor has to really
throw themsel wholeheartedly into you're going to
be in the elements it's going to be wild and it's
probably going to be really uncomfortable and I I
I feel like this trailer maybe gave me a bit much
for my taste of the you know expansion of her Arc
I didn't need to see her with the shaved head in
the trailer I didn't need to see the arm in the
trailer or anything like that I liked having
hints and realizing we'll probably get there
um but that said I really liked how this but how
how did Wolverine get the leather jacket and but
that's the nice thing is I feel like prequels are
often Troublesome because yeah it's like how do we
make this tense and immediate without undercutting
it by the fact that we know what's going to happen
and I think they're in a unique position with a
movie like this to really complement Fury Road but
Al you know these movies are very experiential
and they're very much about just kind of like
being there and the the feeling and the grit of
everything and and as of like a Fury Road living
in in the quieter in between moments like you know
the actual life of the characters they're not like
super dense in terms of like plot elements or even
like character beats but you really feel like you
spent time with and and like did a harrowing thing
with these people and so I feel like this could be
a unique prequel that really can shed a lot of
the baggage many prequels have to and I loved
the prospect of Chris Hemsworth as this uh you
know wild you know a Mad Max villain is going to
be a chance for an actor to really you know take
hold of a role and make it their own he looks like
The Botch Thor yeah but with a complet different
voice to it and then and then his own probably
Australian accent because that's the other thing
too is is that an Australian accent it might be
I'd have to go back in this or was it or was it
his Australian accent peeking through Maybe cuz
you got to cast an Australian actor and I mean you
know this franchise has its roots in Australia you
know mels the Australian originally and stuff
so I feel like sure everyone's favorite person
to be remembered at the moment but uh yeah no I'm
really excited for the both of them and just for
the world in general uh you know you're always
nervous about whether or not they're going to
catch lightning in a bottle the second time and if
it's going to live up to Fury Road but at the same
time uh yeah just liked you know the swath of what
we saw here and uh yeah I'm excited well you know
it it it doesn't it it's not really a criticism
it's just more of an observation when Fury Road
came back after Beyond Thunderdome it's called
Beyond Thunderdome right or is it just called
Thunderdome I think it's Beyond Thunderdome
Mad Max Beyond Thunderdome I'm not even sure
I've watched that one I've not seen Thunder I've
for sure seen Mad Max one and War Warrior I've
not seen yeah yeah regardless uh I mean I've seen
like clips of a Thunderdome um seen a Turner baby
I think I've seen it I must have seen it when
I was like a little kid uh I watched I was like
obsessed special s Gibson movies when I was a kid
so I I imagine I've I feel like I saw it Now's the
Time to go back any um but when when Fury Rogue
came back they they reinvented itself yeah uh
entirely like while you still had you know some
of the the the familiarity of landscape and you
know the just the the aesthetic but they really
redefined everything imagery of what it looks like
and what it feels like and this rapid Pace about
it the frenzyness and it seemed this doesn't look
like a reinvention as much of it as continuing
that style which still feels appropriate and is
exciting you know like at the same time I'm not
here I don't have that same feeling that I have
with Aquaman and the Lost Kingdom trailer where
I'm like this looks like the exact same thing sure
yeah yeah I think that's part of I think that's
why having Hemsworth's role is actually really
refreshing yeah cuz it gives you a chance to think
okay maybe they're going to add some other new and
unique and interesting elements because yeah it's
like you had such a massive length of time between
Thunderdome and Fury Road so that feels like a
massive reinvention I think this franchise is
lucky that it behooves them to kind of disappear
for a long time and come back with a new one and
yeah while this doesn't look like a reinvention
it does look like a movie that's going to carry
itself a bit differently maybe at least have a
bit more character interaction action directly
as part of the focus point of the plot or or
the a little that Happy Feet George Miller
in there definitely and you've got you know the
contrast with like uh uh what is it the the you
know land of many mothers or whatever it is
and and you know these nighttime scenes with
the blue and so you know it's always a Salient
moment for an ecological message as these films
carry so uh yeah yeah well it's got It's it's
got that medieval futuristic flare that I love
so yeah guys I love the trailer I thought it was
excellent and I feel like the trailer delivered
exactly what you'd hope that a return to the Mad
Max world would deliver just with a bit more CGI
that was probably one of the only neg criticisms
I had was like I felt the CGI a little bit the
first one has CGI but but it's not as widely
praised for its practicality and this this CGI
was a little more apparent this time I'm curious
yeah I'm like did you just get a bigger budget
and now you can try this stuff out that could be
fun but on the other hand I am like I don't want
this this to feel too CG cuz the point is like
to feel like you've spent an hour or two in the
dirt yeah yeah but then again the last one was
a nightmare for everyone to put together was but
maybe they need that who knows and and like
Charley ston and Tom Hardy were pretty open
about not getting along yeah and they had to
recut the movie like a bunch of different ways
and times this was that was a really strenuous
experience so I imagine they were might have
been a part of George Miller who was is a senior
was like you know what I got to maybe make a tad
easier on myself right now but guys what did you
think about the trailer leave your thoughts down
below be sure to subscribe leave a like and hey
thank you to our sponsor manscape if you end up
getting some that's great gift to get people and
if you end up getting some let them know reject
Nation send you by using that promo code we'll
see you guys soon thanks for being [Music] here